what is the purpose of act one
well act one gives us all of the context
that we need in order to understand the
story that we're about to watch um and
understand you know
it basically sets up the who wants what
of of your movie so you know if we look
at each
movie as being a story of someone wants
something
uh
once it badly you know goes after it
against big conflict great opposition
then act one sets up all of those pieces
right so it tells us who it tells us
what they want it tells us why they want
it and it tells us what they're up
against
so all of those pieces that sort of
create
the foundation of the story or that like
story engine that we were talking about
earlier that's what act one does it sets
up all of those things so that when we
launch into act two or that like act two
adventure you might have heard it called
when we begin that we have all of the
information that we need in order to
understand who are we watching what are
they trying to do
what are they up against um you know why
do they want it so badly like all of
that's been established so that we can
just watch everything escalate in act
two does that make sense it does and so
as we talked about earlier a lot of
people have a great idea and maybe the
act one is really strong but then
subsequent acts seems like
it's very murky
and that's where the outline would help
them
yeah and i think um just knowing that
you know act one is sort of set up it's
where you set up all of that context um
and then understanding that act two is
escalation so you have all those pieces
in place in act one and then act two is
just playing with them and sort of
forcing them to butt up against each
other and create you know bigger and
bigger conflicts and higher and higher
stakes that's where you know that's the
fun of act two is watching how
everything that you've set up in act one
watching how that
blossoms now you know how or explodes
what mistakes do writers often make in
act one um well i think the the probably
you know big bucket maybe a lot of
different things fall into this but the
the main thing is um
not setting up all of the context that
we need right so not clearly
establishing those
those foundation pieces of the story
those
you know main elements that we need to
understand and appreciate act two so
it's the protagonist it's their story
goal it's where the conflict is coming
from that main conflict or the
antagonist and it's the main thing
that's at stake for the protagonist
right so all of those pieces have to be
in place in act one and when
um when they're not properly established
i mean i think that's the that's the
most common kind of mistake that that
writers make in act one
what mistakes do writers make in act two
oh act two is so wide open right it's
it's the escalation of your story and
it's watching
the thing that you've set up it's
watching it play out but it can go in so
many different directions right
um i think maybe if i had to name one
thing probably the biggest would mistake
would be no i have to i have to do two
so the first one is uh not having their
protagonist pursue the goal
consistently and urgently right because
that's really what moves your story
forward is the protagonist trying to
achieve that thing
um
so that's a big one and then i would say
maybe the other
big one and this is kind of connected is
not escalating things so
sort of hitting the same
note over and over
not intensifying the conflict not
raising the stakes because we want
things to to grow right we want the
conflict to sort of double back on
itself and compound and things to get
harder and more intense and to feel more
important and more urgent for the
protagonist that's you know the
progression of act two should should
have that sort of um building feeling to
it and so i think that's probably the
other the other big one is maybe hitting
the same the same intensity level or
re
you know reworking the same conflict
without um making things harder or
making things more important or urgent
yeah
that was the great thing about hustle is
that so many new things came up without
spoiling it for those who haven't seen
it
once you got through one hurdle a new
one was presented yeah and it's really
not even until the end where i mean
you're like this can't end this way but
anyway yeah and that was you know
they they did such a good job of having
conflict come from so many different
directions too right it wasn't just
that this is a difficult thing to
achieve and so it's you know adam
sandler trying to get the basketball
player in
shape or you know ready to compete at
this level you had other players with
their own agendas you had you know
uh the like we talked about the owner
has his own agenda you know things going
wrong so you had conflict coming from
all these different directions which is
great because again growing the
intensity across act two right that's
what keeps you sort of like leaning in
over and over again going like oh no
what's gonna happen now what's what
could possibly go worse for this
character and and that keeps you kind of
like reinvesting in the outcome
uh i don't know if you've seen did you
watch the series made oh absolutely love
it yes so that is such a good example
just even the first episode of that
series is such a good example of
conflict and building conflict and
nothing going right for the protagonist
like
you know one of the comments i think
that writers hear a lot is like things
are too easy for your protagonist or you
know you need to increase the conflict
or make things hard put your character
through hell right like those are all
kind of tidbits of advice that writers
hear but i feel like
you know writers um
like their characters sometimes and
don't want to make things too hard or or
don't see a way for the character to
get through it if they make things too
hard um but that that first episode of
made was such a good example of like
nothing went right for that character
every single thing went wrong and she
still you know i mean that's kind of the
point is like that makes us root for her
even more because it's everything's
stacked against her and we're we're on
board we're watching we want her to
succeed so i don't think you can ever
make things too hard for your
protagonist
right and and that was one of the things
in listening to the audiobook that it
was based on it was so like i felt so
bad for this woman and and hearing it
and then i guess it was just easier for
me to watch it
um
sort of play out and and i don't know it
was still difficult but yes i mean it
was so many different things being
set up i don't want to give that away
but yeah i absolutely love that yeah i
think that's a great one for writers to
watch if if you ever you've ever gotten
the note of like you're not making
things hard enough on your character you
know watch that and see just how hard
you can you can be on your character
without breaking them you know because i
think maybe that's what scares writers
is like if i make things too hard
i won't be able to figure out how
they're going to keep going or i won't
be able to figure out kind of like how
to get them through it but
that you know dialing up that intensity
is is good it's good for your story and
that's kind of what your audience wants
you know
sure and she would have these meltdowns
and then she would kind of get back on
the horse and then new things would
happen yeah and we like her more for
that too for not giving up you know so
right yeah she was very likable yeah as
a character what is the purpose of act
three well act three is to resolve that
question that you've asked or that main
conflict that you've sort of put your
character into um so it's really it's to
resolve the the question that we've been
exploring over the over the course of
the movie right um when you
uh set up all those pieces that we
talked about in act one all of the
foundation pieces of your story and then
we watch them play out across act two
act three is where you answer that
central dramatic question
wrap up your story resolve that conflict
if you want to think of it that way it's
it's basically basically the resolution
act that's you know you've done all the
escalations and there will still be some
escalations in act three but it's
building toward
uh resolving your your main conflict and
answering that central dramatic question
what mistakes do writers make most often
in act three
uh well i think the big one maybe the
most obvious one would be just not
resolving that you know central dramatic
question or that main conflict that
we're we're you know we're watching the
movie to understand how that's going to
wrap up and so i think um
not resolving that is is maybe the the
biggest or the most common sort of like
newer writer mistake um sometimes
sometimes newer writers um
you know again out of fear maybe that
their story is getting boring or they
don't know how to how to escalate it and
don't know where to go from here they
they take a left turn and start
tracking a different question or a
different conflict that their
protagonist engages in
and we really want act 3 to sort of like
complete that through line not take such
a
hard left that we're now watching a
different movie you know
and is that often when we you know sort
of see comments um underneath the
trailer oh the trailer is better than
the movie
is it often the act three do you think
or the act two or there's no hard and
fast rule yeah i wonder i i don't know
for sure but i would i would guess that
maybe
um a really good trailer was cut from
from a movie that didn't have as much
going on in act 2 and probably act 3 as
well but since act 2 is really kind of
like the movie you know that's what the
movie is it's the character trying to do
this thing it's conflict escalating it's
stakes raising that's really the you
know act two and that is the movie that
we're there we're there to see
so i would imagine if if a trailer or if
a movie is getting those comments of
like the trailer was so much better than
the movie
the good
interesting or entertaining moments were
cut into the trailer and maybe there
just wasn't enough going on in the movie
to sustain interest or you know to to
maintain our
investment in the outcome of it